Привет! В прошлом уроке мы оживили прототип. Навигация, форма, данные, состояние — всё это есть.
Он рабочий, но живёт пока только у тебя на компе по локальному адресу. Никому, кроме тебя, его не открыть.
А дальше нам с ним работать, давать людям на тест, показывать, передавать. Для этого нужна ссылка,
по которой продукт откроется с любого устройства. Сегодня этим мы займёмся, выложим его в сеть. Это
называется «деплой». Сделать это мы можем двумя путями: через готовый сервис или на свой сервер.
Сравним их, а ты выберешь, что тебе ближе. Итак, готовый сервис — это сайты вроде Versil, Netlify,
Cloudflare. Механика простая — ты подключаешь к сервису свой репозиторий, тот самый, куда мы
передавали проект, а он сам собирает сайт, даёт ссылку и пересобирает после каждого пуша. Всё в
браузере, командная строка не нужна, никакого программирования тут не нужно, агент за нас всё
сделает. Плюс этого пути — быстро и бесплатно. Тебе самому ничего не нужно настраивать, всё уже
задумано. Минус в том, что у бесплатных тарифов есть лимиты и, что важно для нас, из России такие
ссылки открываются не всегда стабильно. Второй путь — это свой сервер и сервер у тебя уже есть, тот
самый, который ты арендовал под VPN. На него можно положить приложение и открывать его по адресу
сервера. Плюс здесь в том, что это полный контроль, никаких чужих лимитов и правил. В России у тебя
появляется, потому что VPN на сервере работает, то есть ты к нему спокойно подключаешься и приложение будет работать.
Минус в том, что настройка тут всё-таки нужна. Ну, правда, она будет приведена руками агента. Ну и в том, что
у сервера есть потолок по нагрузке. Для VPN нам не нужен супермощный сервак, поэтому мы берём те, что попроще
и подешевле. Но для полноценных работающих приложений, веб-приложений или сайтов уже нужна
кое-какая производительность. С сервером всё понятно. Он один, тот, который ты уже арендовал. Но сервисов
много, они разные. Я выделил три основных. Давай разберём, какой для чего лучше подходит.
По трафику. У Versile и Netlify на бесплатном тарифе по 100 гигабайт в месяц. А у Cloudflare трафик вообще без лимита.
По коммерции. Versile на бесплатном её запрещает. Только какие-то личные тесты прототипов, то, чем мы сейчас будем заниматься,
и портфолио. Netlify и Cloudflare разрешают коммерцию, Netlify и Cloudflare разрешают коммерцию.
По простоте подключения у Versile проще всех. В пару кликов в Netlify почти так же, но всё-таки
со своими нюансами у Cloudflare шагов чуть больше. Наш выбор сегодня Versile. Он проще всех в настройке
и работает стабильно. Если нужно под коммерцию на бесплатном, то Netlify. И по поводу трафика. 100 гигабайт в месяц.
Сразу поясню про эти 100 гигабайт у Versile и Netlify. 100 гигабайт трафик – это примерно 40-50 тысяч
заходов на твой продукт за месяц. Для U-тестов нам хватит просто с головой. Если ты размещаешь там
портфолио, то это огромный успех, если у тебя такое количество заходов на твое портфолио.
Ну и если в трафике хочешь быть неограничен, то можешь Cloudflare взять, но там нужно будет
маленько больше помучиться. Это можно сделать с агентом. Он скажет, где какой токен создать,
как это подключить. Но нам сейчас это не нужно. И также отдельно хочу обратить твое внимание
на то, как это работает с точки зрения закона. Versile, Netlify, Cloudflare – это всё зарубежные
сервисы. Если ты не просто U-тесты проводишь, а прям хочешь свой продукт там разместить,
то имей в виду, что все данные пользователей улетают за рубеж. Сейчас этого делать нельзя.
Нужно для этого формировать специальный запрос в Роскомнадзор. Плюс там ещё разрешён
только определённый список стран. Короче, проблемы могут быть достаточно большие,
поэтому имей в виду, если ты хочешь собирать в формах какие-то заявки, то твой продукт,
там сайт веб-приложения, должен находиться на территории РФ. Как это сделать?
Арендовать сервер точно так же, как ты делал для VPN, только арендовать его в России.
Итак, переходим в VS Code, привычный нам. Берём директиву Deploy, закидываем её
и запускаем, как обычно. Смотри, директива устроена таким образом, что она сразу
предусматривает два варианта событий, что мы будем пользоваться Versile или заливать
на свой сервак. Как я уже ранее сказал, на Versile мы привязываемся к GitHub продукта.
Последний push, обновление того, что на GitHub, мы делали после создания
Storybook. Поэтому сейчас с уже работающим прототипом, поэтому нам нужно сделать
ещё один push и залить на GitHub актуальную версию нашей сборки. Вообще, на всякий случай,
если ты забудешь, я закинул в директиву этот шаг, он сам должен провести актуализацию.
Но вообще делать это достаточно просто. В этом ничего сложного нет. Просто просим
агента сделать это, и он автоматически выполняет этот шаг. Итак, куда деплоим
проект? Versile, свой VPS, другой сервис. Будем использовать Versile.
Начнём с него. Пока он здесь думает, давай зайдём на Versile. Ссылка на него будет
под уроком. Тебе нужно просто пройти регистрацию. Больше здесь ничего делать
не нужно. Переходим в проекты и видим, что пока у тебя проектов
нет. Здесь он тебе сразу предлагает импортировать проект из твоего
GitHub. Чуть позже этим займёмся. Вернёмся пока в Visual Studio Code. Итак, что он
сейчас делает? Готовит fallback, проверяет токен, сборку. Итак, он автоматически на
GitHub обновил актуальную версию. Теперь нам нужно перейти в Versile и там настроить
подключение. Ещё раз заходим на главную. Проекты, Import Project и здесь
подвязываемся GitHub. Теперь здесь нажимаем Install и тут можешь либо дать
доступ ко всем репозиториям, либо выбрать конкретный. Мне нужен именно
Lesson 4. Всё. Нажимаем установить. Мой репозиторий здесь появился. Нажимаем
Import. Application Preset по умолчанию автоматически определяется. Тут выбран
white, тот, который нам нужен. Здесь, если что, можешь спросить у агента, если не знаешь, какой
там тебе нужен пресет. Но директивы здесь это предусматривает и говорит, что
Versile сам определит. Пресет у нас white. Ну, так и произошло. Больше ничего
менять не нужно. Можем нажать deploy и теперь нужно немного подождать. Итак,
Versile нас поздравил. Всё задеплоилось. Теперь можем перейти на дашборд. Тут у нас
появилась ссылка. Можем по ней перейти. Всё, теперь дашборд. Пополнить баланс. Всё это
по ссылке открывается. Это уже живой сервис в интернете, с которым можно спокойно
взаимодействовать, править и так далее. Теперь скопируем эту ссылку и отправим
агенту. Он её попросил. Тут ещё отдельно отмечу огромный плюс. Он
привязывается к твоему гитхабу. Соответственно, если на гитхабе твоём
что-то меняется, то он автоматически обновляет актуальную версию. Он смотрит
именно на ветку main. Мы уже знаем, что такое ветка. Мы знаем, что это самое главное.
Говорим агенту: Пушни в гид. Обнови ветку main. Он туда всё заливает. Версель это видит и автоматически
обновляет твой прототип. При этом занимает это порядка двух-трёх минут.
Сразу скажу, как лучше работать. Пока ты разрабатываешь там своё
приложение, смотришь, как это всё работает, просишь запускать
локалку. Всегда изменения все будут применяться моментально. Ты сможешь
видеть свою актуальную версию проекта. Пока что-то меняем,
разрабатываем, смотрим именно на локалку. После того, как нас всё устраивает,
мы готовы обновить актуальную версию. Проводим те шаги, которые я ранее сказал. Пушим в гид.
Также по умолчанию нужно авторизироваться в твоём версии, чтобы зайти на
прототип. Это такая стена защиты. Чтобы сделать ссылку полностью
публичной, здесь заходим в овервью, открываем наш
продукт Lesson 4. Здесь у нас есть Deployment Protection. Тыкаем.
Нас перекидывает в настройки в Deployment Protection секцию. Здесь по умолчанию
Версель Authentication включен. Отключаем его. Сохраняем. Скопируем этот текст.
Всё, настройки сохранены. Можно вернуться к агенту и сказать ему об этом. Всё, проверяй.
И также отмечу, что вот эта ссылка - это ссылка на конкретный билд. Чтобы получить стабильную,
нормальную ссылку, нужно копировать именно эту. И тогда все новые апдейты,
которые ты будешь катить, будут у тебя отображаться. Итак, по первому пути мы прошли.
Можем убедиться, что всё работает. Все экраны открываются. Детали и так далее. Всё, что я
на локалке показывал. Теперь ещё раз отмечу, чтобы это обновить, просто говорим агенту:
push new made, обновить на гитхабе. Любая формулировка, которую тебе проще запомнить,
обновляется в гитхабе, обновляется и здесь. Теперь для демонстрации попрошу его ещё и пройти
по второму пути. Я хочу ещё и на сервер отдельно свой личный залить. Давай пройдём
по второму пути из этой директивы. Он здесь сразу запрашивает, что ему нужно. IP-адрес сервера,
пользователь, обычно это root и пароль. Это все те данные, которые ты получил при аренде
сервера и использовал для настройки VPN. Закидываем ему и он разворачивает у тебя на сервере.
После чего он вернёт тебе ссылку в формате просто IP-адреса, потому что домена у тебя нет.
На неё можно перейти и всё будет работать. Ещё отдельно обращу внимание, здесь он будет
немного ругаться, что подключение не защищено. Чтобы такого не было, нужно выписывать сертификат.
Чтобы это сделать, нужно подключить домен. Чтобы домен подключить, его нужно купить и так далее.
Поэтому мы сейчас сертификат выписать не можем, но на работоспособность это не влияет,
просто может возникать уведомление. Переходим и пользуемся.
Итак, на этом всё. Мы рассмотрели два пути диплоя, публикации твоего проекта. Тебе в качестве домашней работы нужно пройти по
одному из них. Хочешь - заливай на сервер, хочешь - заливай на версель.
Но сразу отмечу ещё одну штуку. Если ты на своём сервере, который, скорее всего, у тебя не слишком мощный,
размещаешь, то для того, чтобы по одному-двум людям прогонять у тесты, это подходит всё супер.
Но, если у тебя больше пользователей, если там одновременно пять человек может на нём
находиться, могут возникать проблемы, и это может лагать. Поэтому имей в виду.
Можешь закинуть на версель - это несложно, быстро. Там он выделяет машину помощнее,
но при этом обновление в проде нужно будет немного подождать. В случае же с собственным
сервером, если ты агенту говоришь: "Обнови версию на нашем сервере",
то он делает это быстрее. На этом всё. Удачи с выполнением домашнего задания и увидимся в следующем уроке.